how could you possibly know what
the future holds
because i am from the future
crazy crazy does this
[Music]
come now mary magdalene stand
and be forgiven for your sins but jesus
how can i be forgiven i'm a prostitute
no child you were a prostitute
that life is behind you now mary
magdalene
where are you at [ __ ] oh no jesus i
think it's my pimp
i think he found me
there you are man it took me forever to
find your ass
i'll be looking all over for you you
know how many [ __ ] named mary they're
all been here now get your ass in that
caravan
no no i'm not going with you gala leroy
i'm gonna stay here with jesus what the
flip is this
you washing this feet maybe what i
taught you that
i wrestled you from the fishing village
i cleaned you up and got you out to work
and now that's how you repay me you go
get yourself another pimp
hell no brother she's mine i don't think
you understand
not going with you well i can't afford
to lose her i already lost three [ __ ]
to leprosy all right
all i got left is mary a [ __ ] and two
blind chicks
who actually you know they get requested
a lot don't ask me
how that works get out of here i'm not
going with you galileo
i'm staying here with jesus and i'm
warning you jesus has like
12 followers tell them oh 12.
okay all right so this [ __ ] a
serious pimp no my friend you're
confused
it's 12 men uh are you a gay pimp i'm
not a pimp
i'm a carpenter carpenter
then why does your house look like i've
been busy with non-carpentry work
okay that's it [ __ ] package get in the
caravan and make me some money
no and i don't have any stuff to pack
jesus says we don't need
things what the is this all about money
hell yeah it's all about money brother
i have a saying oh it goes like this
you're gonna love this
shut up it's easier for a camel to pass
through the eye of a needle
than for a rich man to enter the kingdom
of god
oh yeah well i got a saying too
it's easy you know why don't you pass
your own
pass your ass through the needle man
[ __ ] you man
come on girl stairs
i slapped you and you want me to hit you
on the other cheek
that ain't gangsta this is crazy you can
have them i'm done
wait friend so you know that there are
no hard feelings
would you care to join us for dinner
[Music]
what y'all have
the second amendment of the constitution
states that a well-regulated militia
being necessary for the security of a
free state
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be in fringe hear him yes
please gentlemen we need all of your
signatures gentlemen
a point of order what if
someone made a gun that could shoot say
50 people in 30 seconds
congressman peale we have many orders of
business today
one of which is not judging your sense
of humor
prodigious as it may be
then one man would be able to walk into
a crowded
area and kill scores upon scores of
people
before anyone would have a chance to
stop him
congressman peel where are you getting
these hair-brained ideas
how could you possibly know what
the future holds
because i am from the future
i know what this amendment will bring
and i cannot let any of you sign it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i did it did you see the
the muskets he had magnificent
and me the quill so i can draw them
before i forget
damn it
all right y'all gather round gather
round welcome
gentlemen what a beautiful and blessed
day
for an auction all right y'all get on up
there
put that whip down and see what happens
though straight up i don't care what
plantation i end up
on i'm straight staging a revolt in this
[ __ ] hills yeah
we have lot a lot b and lot
c uh three dollars on lotte four dollars
five five dollars going once twice three
times
sold lotte goes to the man in the black
hat
i mean good yeah i'm glad i didn't get
sold because i don't want to be owned by
another human being whoever buys me
they better kill me the first day i'm
gonna go buck wild on the whole
operation
next one get up on up there now
oh it's okay
six dollars on lotte seven dollars eight
nine nine dollar going once twice three
times
sold okay well you have to buy that dude
it's a no-brainer i mean that guy's a
huge
massive individual that's two of me
anybody would buy him i'd buy that dude
my question is
how did they catch him next
okay two dollars on lotte
two dollars going once twice three times
soul see now that surprises me that is
interesting to say the least well it
just seems like at a certain point
it's like do they even know what they're
looking i mean like the whole criteria
seems
just a little inconsistent i mean at
some point i want to be on live yeah
can the brother get on lotte next
oh here we go here we go put a pleasure
give him hail all right okay
eight dollars on la day going once twice
three times whole how does that no
not true what you have to say that's
gobbledygook okay that can't be true
cause what can you listen to
do look at him what could he pick a
cotton plan is like this tall
yes i'm saying no offense brother i'm
just saying oh since taken
what if i was going am i wrong is he's
not shorty
shorts but you are actually short in
real life
in the world enough
i will not have my reputation tainted
selling superficial
bigoted slaves superficial did that
really just come out of your mouth
that's it this auction's over auctions
no is it it ain't over it's not over i'm
strong y'all
i'm very sure i can sleep in a bucket
i'm fast i got stamina no i don't look
at me no no magic
my worst quality is that i'm a
perfectionist have i mentioned this
docile i am agreeable to a fault
you should have seen the dude who asked
me to get on the boat when we came over
here not a violent bomb
no big deal never seen a boat in my life
[Music]
uh
[Music]
are you miss tubman the name's harriet
well thank god in heaven for the work
that you're doing harriet
before you thank me let me tell you
i've led hundreds of slaves to freedom
through this here
underground railroad
but it ain't gonna be easy
are you ready all right
then hike up your britches and follow me
to friday
[Music]
watch this black molasses
where is she now
[Music]
that was a easy part now stay close
this next 500 miles gets a little sticky
[Music]
forget this man i'm going back
you guys see anything nothing yet okay
we'll uh wait until dark and then sneak
back across the line and
rejoin our unit do you guys hear
something
[Music]
[Music]
oh
these americans prove to be no obstacle
at all
search the hotel yeah
we've done well to secure this position
i could bode well for promotion
speaking of which guess who i saw at the
markets the other day
oh oh i don't know adolf hitler
i love hitler who doesn't but you ever
see him in person
oh yeah at the nuremberg rally it was
very inspirational i know it was i was
there everyone was there
but up close it's a whole different
thing
for instance it was the weekend and the
little hairs had just started to grow on
the sides of the mustache like
this so i walk up to hitler
casual comment on that's that's rude i'm
in the middle of a story
you're not interested in a story about
off yoga yeah okay good
ava was there as well taller than you
think
or hit the shorter hard to say but
anywho
i'm buying some bread hitler's buying
some bread um
i must so i'm i'm assuming you got a
better hitler story
but no but maybe don't interrupt
yes sir so i give him a salute and he
gives me one of those half hitler
salutes you know down low very cool
right you know here's what you forget
yeah
he doesn't say heil hitler isn't that
funny
huh oh wait i think maybe next time i'll
tell him
how uninterested you are in my story oh
no no this is jealousy thing no no no
no i didn't meet hitler to hurt your
feelings
proceed of course so i say to hitler
i've actually been quite busy hitler
laughs
and then says you and me both
i mean he's the fjora it's so funny
because it's an understatement
i mean he's super busy as hitler was
taking his lead
how do you interrupt you right do you
speak during the cinema
the story has a build but if you keep
interrupting you kill the momentum but
i'm trying to tell you
that body is moving that's ridiculous
the americans are all dead
but if it keeps you from interrupting my
awesome hitler story
i'll prove it to you sir
[Music]
[Music]
oh i'll never get used to those final
death rose
death throats heir mueller
what is wrong with you those are not
death throats
you are being an idiot
insubordinate and cherish
pity this is the best part of the story
as hitler was taking his leave of me he
said well
there's no point in getting that if
you're not going to get and at the same
time
hitler said cheese i said cheese and
then hitler and i both said
jinx voters was like two regular
everyday peoples
you guys missed the first part but this
is all about hitler
free at last free at last thank god
almighty we are free at last
ladies and gentlemen please welcome your
next speaker the reverend robert jones
[Applause]
how am i supposed to follow that i can't
nobody can follow that
oh all right
good afternoon um
that that is the the best speech i've
ever heard
in my entire life ever
i have never heard a better speech
and now it is my turn to speak
huh we put this running order together
right
you know um dr king
he actually covered a lot a lot of what
i was gonna say um
you know my my speech is uh uh you're
gonna find this funny y'all
my speech was actually called uh a
vision for the future
i'm not saying that dr king copied my
speech i'm
no no no i'm saying i'm not saying that
i'm not saying he tried to copy it watch
out listen to him but i'm
wow you know what no come on i'm just
saying
i'm just saying i'm just saying it's a
joke
did i not say it like a joke okay
nope apparently i have six more minutes
let's see a red red hills of georgia he
got that out there
okay you know what all right here's
something here's up new here's something
uh brand new how okay this is off me
talking off the top of my head here
everybody uh wha
how about if we let uh black people
enslave
white people for okay you know that
sounded a lot better in my head before i
said it
so that's uh that wouldn't work
is it warm is anybody else warm
whoa okay
okay okay here's what we're gonna do
here's what we're gonna do all right dr
king
talked about um uh all the races coming
together right right so what i want
every negro to do here today is find the
nearest white person and give him a hug
just just give him a hug okay nope sir
you're not being attacked you're not
being attacked you're being hugged okay
everybody take it easy here okay
everybody relax you know what we don't
need 10 negroes hugging one white person
okay
let's just let's yo that's the new rule
not 10 on one
one-on-one we'll just take turns and
everything okay so everybody relax okay
oh my goodness sir she doesn't need to
be defended she doesn't need to be
better she's okay
she's okay okay all right so man okay
officer is that necessary i don't think
it's necessary officers
no man please please take it easy sir we
everybody take it easy all right
[Music]
oh